the film opens with a happy children's
song which is promptly interrupted by
Lemony Snicket a mysterious narrator
addressing the audience directly he
warns us that we should not expect a
pleasant movie instead the movie is a
tale of Orphans various weird dangerous
things and Misfortune we are introduced
to the bottle a children 14-year-old
Violet the eldest and a resourceful
inventor the middle child class an Avid
Reader who remembers every word that he
has ever read and the youngest Sunny a
quick-witted child with sharp teeth with
which she bites down almost every
everything one day while playing on the
Briney Beach the children notice Mr Poe
the bottle air family Banker approaches
them Mr Poe informs the children about
their unfortunate fate their parents
have perished in a fire which also
completely destroyed their magnificent
Mansion as the children travel back to
their home Lemony Snicket narrates that
the exact cause of the fire is unknown
however he and his friends have
discovered that it was due to the
refraction and convergence of light from
a great distance the fire had devoured
everything leaving behind a smoldering
pile of as and unanswered questions
about the bottle A's parents hidden in
his father's desk CL stumbles upon a
brass spy glass sparking curiosity and a
yearning for more answers but the harsh
reality is that the once joyful bodair
children are now orphans facing an
uncertain future Mr Poe their banker and
temporary Guardian informs them that he
would handle their parents' remaining
assets until they came of age however Mr
Poe is obligated to entrust them to
their nearest relative Count Olaf who is
a distant third or fourth cousin or so
Mr Poe thinks as their car rolls to a
stop a burst of delight initially washes
over the children a Charming Little
House adorned with pink flowers seems to
promise a Haven but their Joy was
shortlived expressing her condolences
for their loss the friendly Justice
Strauss clarifies that the lovely home
was her and Count Olaf lived across the
street turning the corner a grim reality
awaits them a crumbling dilapidated
house stands in stark contrast to the
Splendor they were used to Count Olaf
with his exaggerated theatricality
welcomes the in but despite his
over-the-top performance glimpses of his
greed and cunning sneak through after Mr
Poe confirms the court would finalize
the custody Arrangements on Thursday
Olaf swiftly ushers him out of the house
leaving the bottle a orphans alone with
their fears and uncertainty after the
banker leaves count Olaf's facade
crumbles he boasts about his soon to be
wealth despite the dilapidated state of
his house he gives the children a grim
tour showcasing the rat infested cuups
decaying backyard and their own
crumbling bedroom everything seemed
seems on the verge of falling apart
every morning Olf Saddles the children
with endless chores while he spends his
time practicing acting with his troop
one day while the children scrub the
floor Olaf demands dinner for him and
his troop by 8:00 P.M Violet and klouse
with their combined wit and
resourcefulness managed to whip up pasta
however Olaf throws a tantrum demanding
roast beef and slapping class for not
anticipating his desires he gleefully
Reveals His plan to enjoy their parents'
money while they toil for him PL reminds
Olaf of the law preventing him from
accessing the fortune until Violet's
18th birthday Violet threatens to expose
his mistreatment to Mr Poe in
retaliation Olaf locks them in their
Bleak bedroom desperate klous begins
tearing the window apart trying to
escape he even blames their parents for
not leaving a plan Violet intervenes
calming him down and building a small
Sanctuary with salvaged items from their
burnt Mansion the day arrives for the
court hearing unfortunately for the
children Olaf gains legal guardianship
while driving back he FS regret for his
behavior offering to be a good parent as
an olive branch he stops at a general
store for drinks however this is all a
calculated act he Parks the car on a
train track locking the doors to trap
the children inside with a Sinister grin
he waltzes into the store wasting time
until the train hurdles towards them
inside the car Violet receives a call
from Mr Poe desperately she attempts to
explain their predicament the car is
about to be hit by a train Mr Po ever
the oblivious Banker misinterprets her
please believing the children are
driving the car coincidentally he's
driving next to a train himself and
dismisses her call promising to call
later dejected but determined Violet
seeks clouse's help he recalls from his
vast knowledge of trains that their
tracks can be switched with a determined
glint in her eyes Violet gathers her
hair and with Sunny's unwavering
optimism manages to open a window using
a bobblehead as their unlikely
projectile they successfully divert the
train narrowly avoiding disaster moments
later Mr Poe arrives on the scene seeing
Sunny strapped in the front seat he
misconstrues the situation believing
she's the driver although Olaf tries to
mask his Sinister attempt Mr Po sees
through his facade deciding that
allowing a small child to drive is
unacceptable he declares the children
will no longer be in Olaf's custody Mr
Po takes the children to Dr Montgomery
Montgomery a herpetologist by profession
a stark contrast to Olaf Dr Montgomery's
home is clean and wellmaintained with
one unusual exception an elaborate
indoor garden teeming with snakes of all
kinds from a double-headed Cobra to a
three-eyed Toad the collection is truly
bizarre the newest addition a large
black Tanzanian Viper sends shivers down
their spines especially when it nearly
attempts to bite Sunny Dr Montgomery
assures the children that despite its
fearsome name the Viper is gentle and
shy and was not trying to bite the kid
as Dr Montgomery excitedly announces a
plan trip to Peru class notices a brass
spy glass nestled on his hip it's
identical to the one he saw in his burnt
house before he can question it dinner
has served a delicious respit from their
recent ordeal after a satisfying meal Dr
Montgomery affectionately known as Uncle
Monty sings the children the same song
their parents used to sing to them he
Reveals His Own tragic past having lost
his children wife and home to a fire
mirroring the bottle A's own devastating
loss the next morning the children
receive an unwelcomed surprise their
trip to Peru is jeopardized Gustavo Dr
Montgomery's assistant has suddenly
Fallen L and his replacement a
mysterious Italian gentleman named
Stefano arrives on short notice the
children recognizing count Olaf's
disguise are instantly suspicious
however Dr Montgomery ever trusting
dismisses their concerns believing them
to be rude towards Stefano the children
try to warn Uncle Monty but their
attempts are met with misunderstanding
Dr Montgomery believes Stefano is an
impostor after his prized Tanzanian
Viper the children try to explain the
truth but Stefano intervenes urging them
to sleep tragedy strikes the next
morning Dr Montgomery is found dead
shattering the children's hopes of
finding a loving family the police
arrive to investigate and Stefano
cleverly manipulates them into believing
the Viper is responsible the children
desperately try to reveal Stefano's true
identity but neither the police nor Mr
Poe believe them in a moment of
Brilliance Sunny approaches the Viper
and instead of attacking it gently plays
with her before the police can confront
Stefano he flees Mr Poe still oblivious
to Olaf's true nature takes the children
to their next Guardian Aunt Josephine
who lives in a precarious wooden house
perched precariously over lake lacos
plos is puzzled by the lack of any close
relatives among their Guardians upon
meeting at Josephine they discover a
woman obsessed with grammar and plagued
by constant fear of disaster she warns
them against entering the house too
quickly fearing they might trip and be
decapitated inside her paranoia
manifests in various ways she refuses to
turn on the radiator for fear of
explosion forbids using doorknobs as
they might shatter and injure her eye
and serves cucumber juice for dinner
fearing the stove might burst into
flames she even prevents class from
standing near the refrigerator terrified
it might fall and crush him over dinner
she shows them a photo album revealing a
past life far removed from her current
anxieties the pictures depict a young
free-spirited Josephine taming lions and
enjoying life one photograph captures
her Dr Montgomery and the bot A's
parents together all sporting the same
brass spy glass clouse had noticed
earlier however upon questioning from
clouse Joseph quickly hides the photo
leaving a trail of unanswered questions
Josephine warns the children about the
leeches in the lake blind creatures that
swarm towards humans who have just eaten
she reveals that her husband Ike died
after ignoring her advice to wait an
hour before swimming in the lake when
she sees clous entering ik's room she
asks him to respect her deceased
husband's memory by staying out
determined to help their aunt overcome
her fears the children and Josephine
venture out to the market there they
encounter Captain sham a self-proclaimed
fisherman with a love for grammar the
children recognize count Olaf's disguise
but Josephine Charmed by his image Falls
for his trap she invites him home while
leaving the children to shop for dinner
later that evening amidst thunder and
rain the children returned to find a
broken window and a suicide note with
glaring grammatical errors CLA deduces
that this is a clue not a genuine
suicide note and that Josephine is
hiding in curdled cave before they can
leave the storm intensifies doors blow
off and class discovers photos of
burning houses and a Myster mysterious
eye symbol in Ike's room he wonders why
Ike was investigating fires suddenly
everything Josephine warned them about
happens the fridge Falls the stove
catches fire and the glass doorknob
shatters when the storm subsides they
find themselves on a detached piece of
wood precariously hanging over the water
Violet ever resourceful saves the day
and rescues her siblings refusing to
involve the authorities Violet urges
class to sail to curdled cave where they
find a sobbing but grateful Josephine
initially she refuses to return even
after learning about Captain Shams
forged while granting him custody of the
children however class exploits her fear
of Realtors and convinces her to board
the boat on the boat clous shows
Josephine the paper with the eye symbol
and asks about Ike's investigation she
reveals that they were all investigating
fires and the bottle a parents as
leaders had discovered the answer
leading to their deaths before she can
elaborate their boat is attacked by
leeches Count Olaf everpresent in their
Misfortune arrives and takes the
children away leaving Josephine to the
leeches in a stroke of luck Mr Poe and
the police arrive and C Olaf quickly
pretends to be rescuing the children
from the leeches the ever gullible Mr
Poe interprets this as an act of heroism
and rewards Olaf with custody once more
however a Twist awaits Mr Poe clarifies
that any harm to the children would
result in The Inheritance being
transferred to a blood relative or
spouse a wicked smile spreads across
Olaf's face as he invites Mr Poe and the
police to witness his new Play Count
Olaf and the marvelous marriage the
entire town gathers for the play as
Violet and clouse suspect Olaf's true
intentions Olaf's plan unfolds Violet
plays the bride to his groom and Justice
stuss their neighbor into real justice
of peace is manipulated into unknowingly
becoming the efficient on stage blinded
by the excitement of her acting debut
Justice stuss fails to realize Olaf's
scheme to use her to validate a real
marriage with Violet when Violet refuses
to participate Olaf reveals Sunny locked
in a bird cage high at top the tower
threatening to drop her if Violet
doesn't comply clouse escapes the play
and reaches the tower's base inspired by
his sister's resourcefulness he uses an
old umbrella has a hook to climb
reaching the top he discovers a large
lens attached to a movable frame on the
window when the Sun Peaks through the
clouds its Rays hit the lens and class
realizes the truth Olaf used this lens
to focus sunlight and set the bottle a
mansion Ablaze the mysterious eye symbol
he found in Ike's room was none other
than this very window with the lens back
on stage Violet had has signed the
marriage papers and Olaf sheds his mask
of Innocence he gleefully boasts of his
elaborate plan using the play as a
facade to marry Violet and claim the
fortune he brandishes the marriage
certificate mocking the town's people
for not believing the botle a but
suddenly as the sun briefly shines
through the clouds clous uses the lens
to burn the certificate leading to
Olaf's arrest he faces life imprisonment
subjected to the same torment he
inflicted on the children however later
reports reveal that a jury of his
friends overturned his convictions and
Count Olaf vanished from the town the
bottle air Children Are Back In The
Familiar back seat of Mr Po's car
searching for yet another Guardian they
make a final stop at the charred remains
of their mansion here they find mail
address to them it's a letter from their
parents filled with exciting stories of
their travels and encounters with
amazing people the letter ends with a
reassuring message no matter where they
are the children will always have a home
in each other a symbol of welcoming them
into their secret society a brass spy
glass accompanies the letter as the
movie ends Lemony Snicket the narrator
finishes writing his book about the
bottle air children's Journey instead of
taking it to a publisher the mysterious
narrator who is also sporting a brass
spy glass hides it behind the clock face
in a giant Clock Tower and leaves for
someone to find it